hi everyone thank you for joining us
today I'm really excited to be here
today to talk to you about an exciting
topic which is AI my name is Samir I'm a
gaming technical specialist at Google
cloud and I'm based in Tokyo you might
wonder also like what's a gaming
technical specialist like I have was a
lot of my friend asking me what I do in
my daily job the answer is very simple I
just play games and but I'm not joking
my coworkers are always asking me like
what are you doing they see on my phone
I'm just playing but no more seriously
I'm helping gaming studios in Asia
making innovative backends on GCP so
today I'll be talking to you about what
we offer in Google cloud around AI but
then I will give the the space to DNA
who are on the stage with me today that
will talk about their experience on how
they simulated human players in there
one of the more popular game and
building that on a scalable and robust
back-end on Google machine learning
engine so they will come back on stage I
do a bit of bit of introduction and I
think I don't even have oh yeah this so
they will come back in a few minutes
thank you so Google is working with the
game industry to help developers succeed
and cloud is at the center of those
efforts we want to help create great
games and connect with players globally
and scale your business so we're working
with other Google teams to bring this
vision to life so before diving into the
concrete implementation of DNA in the AI
space let me talk to you about different
application of AI in games and I won't
talk to you about all of them but just a
few that I really like for instance the
first one being able to play against a
would that simulate a pro players so we
don't that'd be cool to be able to
compare your skill to the best very best
in the game usually you don't have the
opportunity to play again a pro player
if you probably not one so isn't that
cool to do that think also a similar way
instead of having a boat that simulator
a pro player it could simulate yourself
and think about you're playing a
multiplayer game again someone online
and that person that you play against
disconnect and the games ends
prematurely isn't that frustrating me I
way I play a lot online and when it
happens I feel really frustrated because
I want it to end the game but think
about if you had a boat that could
simulate use of like the way you play so
you're playing online your connection
drops but you've been replaced at that
moment by a boat that play like you your
opponent might not even notice that he's
playing again I bought and the game
could end wouldn't that be a great user
experience there's also use cases that I
will talk a bit later that don't even
require expertise in ml but I want you
to realize that AI has its place in
games and it really helped increase the
user experience but also in very
critical things like monetization or
clear retention so not only the AI has
its place in the game but games are also
an ideal environment for AI so games
plays a big part on how we develop
technology in Google and alphabet deep
mind is a very good example of that the
mine is a artificial intelligence
research company from Atari to the
ancient game of Go they use increasingly
challenging game the challenging game
environment as a testing ground to
develop more capable and generalizable
systems that can navigate to extreme
complexity so the natural next step in
their research program was the real-time
strategy game Starcraft so Starcraft 2
because it pulls yet more hot
problems to solve in areas of computer
science like planning dealing with
uncertainty and spatial reasoning I
don't know if you have seen what has
been done recently in the with the
Starcraft pit they could make a pot that
could beat the top pro player of
Starcraft 2 so that's really impressing
how you go how they have done and you
can see the vision of how AI is going
in-game so unfortunately not everyone is
deep mind and not everyone has their ml
expert the data is overwhelming the word
is lacking of ML expert from the 21
million developers you have less than a
million data scientists and even less ml
experts so I will go or a Google cloud
is to help anyone use machine learning
to build new application or to add
intelligence to existing ones we've
taken the best of Google machine
learning and offer it as a fully trained
model we are accessible via API so all
of our pre trained models are built on
years of Google expertise and we find
training data from vision recognition to
natural language processing you can use
our API to teach your application to see
hear or interact with user in a complete
different way so what are the different
AI journeys that are offered by Google
cloud there is like few if you see on
the top the prepackaged solution so we
have prepackaged yet powerful AI
solutions for game studio new on there a
IPS pierpass with very limited resource
or very limited ml expertise on the
bottom part for advanced studios with AI
journey like advance on their AI Johnny
who has data scientists of ML expert
that can build and train ml models
themselves using tensorflow cloud cpu or
cloud machine learning engine and in the
middle
you have a new pathway that's supposed
to help you and board on machine
learning and do more advanced stuff
without even that America at ease so you
will find cloud auto ml so cloud auto ml
helps game studio with limited ml
expertise to start building their own
high quality models but using a GUI and
on the right side you see you'll find
big query ml so bigquery for those that
are not very familiar it's a data
warehouse that Google cloud is offering
on their cloud and it offers an
additional functionality where you can
create machine learning model just using
standard sequel so solution like cloud
o2 ml or bigquery ml
they are here to make even AI expert be
more productive but even help and it
will also help the less yield engineer
that are not very familiar with mo to
build powerful AI systems that they
could only dreamed of previously so this
is the only sales pitch that I will put
today in my presentation just like
telling you why customers are choosing
Google for AI I'll go very quickly over
it so there's four points one is scale
so we offer a cloud called Google cloud
platform you start using our cloud you
get access to thousand of instances so
if you have heavy combination
combination or workload you get access
to the compute that you need to do that
to the speed so Google cloud is the only
one to offer what we call TP use so I
don't know if you have ever heard of
what TPU is it sounds like a CPU GPU so
TPU is a tensor profits processing unit
so it's a process or that we customly
made for the machine learning use case
to understand like how faster is it
usually when you train a model most of
the time you will use a GPU to have like
a higher computational power and if you
compare what cloud TPU can do using a
resin 850 model you can benchmark it and
using a single cloud TPU
is eight cores and 64 gig of ram it goes
eight point four times faster than
nvidia p hundred GPU and it still go
five times faster than nvidia 300 GPU so
it's extremely fast if you try with
other inception model like inception v3
you get similar result so Google Cloud
is the only one to offer that cloud TPU
and can really accelerate your machine
learning workload the third one is
quality I think you have already tried
google photo google translator google
assistant and you can see how accurate
google photo can be when you start
searching for anything that you have in
your google photo albums I often like
search hamburger because I like to show
to my friend like at the last hamburger
I've eaten and I put a hamburger and I
get the list of all the burgers that I
ate in the past is very accurate so even
like when you search like a card at some
time like I took photo of my ID or my
credit card and I put like card or ID
and I will find those photos that I
otherwise I wouldn't be able to find
accessibility this one is the two
product like outside the free train
model that we are offering we have the
intermediate solution like cloud auto ml
and bigquery ml that will help you make
ml more accessible to everyone so to
conclude my part I have just only three
words like don't miss out a Isis at your
fingertips and you can start right now
adding intelligence to your application
like existing one or to a new one using
those pre trained model or even custom
model using cloud or two ml if you
already an ml expert then you can jump
directly to tensorflow cloud ml engine
to run your own custom model so this is
a in a formal side like without further
ado I want to introduce you to folks
from DNA that will talk about the
experience creating an AI and a deck
recommendation system in in one of their
most popular MOBA game in Japan on GCP
so I let you enjoy like continued this
presentation thank you
so thank you Samir for the introduction
and we are from DNA which is one of the
largest game publisher in Japan and
today we would like to share our
implementation on gaming so far we have
released two applications that we are
going to talk about the motivation
implementation and the outcomes of our
cases so my name is Ernesto and I'm
leading this project also let me
introduce each Tanaka
he's a data scientist and built our AI
models so in this part both of us will
present so to be you is this work has
been accomplished by for machine
learning engineers and lots of
collaborators from gaming team each of
us have our own area of expertise and I
really love this team so let's start so
I think most of you are not so funny as
DNA our company is one of the largest
internet companies in Japan although we
have various business domains such as
game automotive and sports most of the
revenue comes from games actually we're
providing in dozens of in-house game
titles and the other publishers titles
and maybe some of you may know that we
have an alliance with Nintendo for
example our company is the in charge of
the backend system from Super Mario run
so this is who we are in this session
we'll focus on the in-house game title
the octane or sironia so first I'd like
to talk about the problem we had and how
we challenged to solve these issues so
this game the octane ellonija is the
strategy of game the players action is
based on the board game called acero or
River C and the player put black and
white pieces alternatively what is
unique about this game is that each
pieces has its own skills and which has
strategic components to the battles
actually when you start playing the game
there are a variety of play stars
endless exploration is required to
master the game this title was released
three years ago and fortunately is still
growing we have more than 23 million
downloads so far and the service region
is expanding gradually and of course I
hope in the future I I hope in the
future we can release in the US as well
so in Austria there is a concept of Dex
and the characters before starting a
battle prior consisted egg which is
composed of the characters 16 characters
among more than 3000 options and each
character has its own skills and the
players have to choose consistent
characters according to the play at play
styles as you can imagine the number of
combination is extreme and it's not easy
for beginners to learn how to build an
optimal deck another issue here is that
the building an optimal deck requires to
learn effective strategies through the
process of trial and error so let me
explain why this is a program generally
speaking if the game has complex
features which can be strapped players
from continuing the game the churn rate
increases and impacts the future revenue
right for example there is an estimation
that just a few points decreasing the 30
day turn rate can increase the revenue
by 20 to 30% in the future back to Sonia
we actually have a high generate so we
are in trouble this is partly because
the game is complex and lacks sufficient
or need support therefore it's hard for
beginners to construct an optimal deck
also there is a problem that they don't
have a good plug a place for practice in
order to improve their their battle
skills for instance we only have to
battle options for beginners why is any
PC battle in which they battle against
very very weak opponents and the other
is PvP battle in which they are
frequently matched with skilled players
so we needed an opponent whose play
level is similar to the [ __ ] so
that's our program setting so let's see
our approach to support beginners we
have developed two functions the first
one is the deck recommendation system
which selects appropriate chapters from
players piece box and we are using the
association analysis to provide a better
recommendation the second one is the
battle III which we call author onea
dojo in this function we are pro and
developed AI that can play at any levels
a deep neural network is used for DCI
later iki will explain how these
techniques are used in our cases so by
the way from the machine Ani perspective
we need to prepare the data to build
such a eyes we recording various kind of
in-game data since the release of the
game such as deck logs and the battle
logs so we have a good amount of data
before starting this project so in our
cases we use the data for the last nine
months s which contains billions of log
entries and then we filter the data by
player skills and augmented the original
data in the battle cases the image on
the right side is an example a battle
log which is formatting with formatted
in JSON and describes enter States and
the actual information with the battle
the bottom diagram shows rough data
pipeline and bigquery did a very good
job at this pre-processing phase for
instance it can handle even a trilobite
order of data very fast and we could
reduce the processing time just very big
you could handle our data in a few
minutes
which took an hour on on prime Hadoop
clusters
and we also love that BQ is easy to
collaborate with other CCP services so
here I want to stress that our air has
been successfully built by sufficient
amount of data and reliable pipeline so
let's see how each of the cases works
this is the rough overview of the
recommendation system so we first
exploit pre-processed their flocks to
extract information about how each
characters are associated which is
called association rules with this
analysis we can score the strength of
the relationship across all the pair of
characters then if there is a request
from the player the recommendation
server receives a set of characters in
the players peace box and it fills all
the 16 characters according to the score
of the Association rules this function
is very flexible and the player can
specify the archetype the cost and the
favored characters to be included in the
deck regarding kpi's we're monitoring
several metrics for instance we are
watching how many players have used a
recommendation system whether the
recommended deck has been accepted and
whether the deck contributed to the
player's internals a win rate in battles
so as for the dojo players can battle
against AI with various archetypes and
strengths here we train a deep neural
network from pre-processed battle logs
the client send current game status and
the battle API server returns the
inference of neural network at every
turn of the game
as for the matrix we're monitoring how
frequently that also is used and whether
the strengths of AI was sufficient in
terms of win rate so these two a eyes
have already been released and we are
observing very positive
so before showing the result I'll pass
that talk to Ichi he'll talk about
technical details and some tips for
building AI systems thank you Jim
so I Mickey and a data scientist at DNA
so I'm one of the developers that
created our gaming a system by using the
data analysis data science and machine
learning so today I'll talk about the
technical details overuse cases with GCP
so now let's look at the story of the
technical part so first I'd like to
start by the deck recommendation this is
the outline of the de Klerk human dargor
ISM and firstly the de Klerk mendacious
algorithms receives a receive some
inputs from a from a player such as the
archetype that cost the possessed
characters and characters the player
wants to use next the algorithm select a
leader by by using the result of
Association analysis and statistical
data so in this algorithm cactus is
chosen first and the next character the
circuit based on the leader the wear
associate characters simply selected
based on the result of Association
analysis if the deck is not four of the
16 characters the another character is
searched as the base character after
repeating this procedure several times
the recommended tag is proposed to the
player if the game is different the way
of fine tuning is also different so in
no game the Octonauts aronia for example
we mailed additional lures
to decided leader and we've checked it
occupation of the skills in deck
building I'd like to give the brief
explanation about how to extract the
relationships between characters
in a recommendation we are using
Association analysis the Association
analysis is a rule-based machine
learning method for discovering
interesting relations between contents
in large data set so this method can
perform high speed calculation to
extract many relationships and extracted
relations easy to understand and very
useful in various settings the regions
are evaluated with some metrics like the
strength of the connections and
frequency of the rules or patterns our
recommendation visit deck by selecting a
character she casually with strong
relationships most another so this
method can handle various kind of data
easily so I think this technique is
applicable to many games next I've
talked about the system so we built our
applications such as tech recommendation
and different Airport with disappea so
why did we choose choose DCP for our
other systems there are two main reasons
the first one is the powerful and
flexible tools for machine learning and
data science in the data analysis we
often try to investigate the data
visualize it and creates the prototype
models the DCP services for big data
analysis make it possible as such as
bigquery cloud data love and Google
compute engine the DCP services for crud
crud storage provides the scale and
fastest rate services for large data and
it helps us to manage the big data and a
lot of machine learning models about mm
engine we can deploy a model to credible
engine easily and quickly and it also
provides user friendly production api's
additionally GCP provides many services
to perform as learning each century for
example we are you we are planning to
use gke container service and redeemer
engine training with custom functions
for scalable and distributed memory
training the second one is the scarab
and robust infrastructure services we
can run the application easily by using
Google App Engine with several
programming languages like Python and go
language and we can check many metrics
of system performances through stock
driver logging and so on
I'd like to emphasize auto scaling
function of G it's very great service
because new instances increased was
stopped in response to traffic and and
the Resta distributed to the instances
automatically so these DCP services easy
to integrate into the same systems so
for these reasons we are choosing DCP
for viral systems also the system
architecture of technical recommendation
with DCP first the clocks are saved in
bigquery which are used to extract the
rules we said the cron scheduler to
perform the batch processing of the
association analysis in Google compute
engine and in order to catch up the
trendex with latest characters we are
performing about processing everyday
[Music]
functions processes result of
Association analysis and updates the
data for production environment called
function checks if the data is updated
correctly for example is the data sizes
too small or large and we are using
Google App Engine Python 2.7 for the
recommendation APR 7
and finally it returns a recommended
deck to the prayer one of the not
worship point is G a Python 3.7 was
generally available at the end of last
year so we could use it just at the
right time as a result of the operate to
a Python 3.7 we don't need to change our
course that we had already developed in
Python 3
so far I've explained the algorithm and
the system with a recommendation let's
move on to the next topic deep learning
about its author own a dojo dojo means
training will learn to improve the
playing skills this is the overview of
the training in different airport the
planning is suitable for case to them
the many complicated features such as
state of board the X hands skills and
combinations of the features that the
planning abode receives the state of
battle from a client the information
battle is converted to the new makeup
features which I use as the input of the
deepening the network around the actions
of top tier players as binary
classification and finally the different
model outputs the values of each action
that will be used to decide the next
action here we used modern-day million
baht of Records in the training next I
will show the system available first of
all talk about the training phase a
large number bottom records in PvP is
several cloud storage through bigquery
and training process consists of
pre-processing of the features and the
model training which are running in
Google compute engine
at the pre-processing the features are
generated on demand from the part of
Records by emulating the game in our
case we created the custom function of
data generator that creates the feature
during the training after the training
the 20 M model is 17 credits to deploy
on to the credible engine next I move on
to the inference phase so please take a
look at the communication between the
client inference API server on the left
of the slide the battle records are
posted to the inference API server from
the client which plays a battle event
against the Habad the inference a pious
server reproduces a battle from the
liquid extracts of features and
interests ends that features to the
prediction API was academia engine on a
production of code my engine is very
useful because it is optimized to run
the models with lord entity within your
time
engine uses train the model studying DCs
and returns the values of each action
the values are sent back to the client
and the client moves for the butter step
by selecting selecting and best action
according to the values that's the
overall communication between the client
to the service Google App Engine and
cloud a mirror engine can auto scale in
response to the load on the server
that's a very good function so by taking
the benefit of the auto scaling we can
manage a large amount of requests lastly
I'll touch on that they're going to a
topic the testing of the systems so why
should we test the systems I mentioned
in the last slide query engine can auto
scale quickly
it's good so yes that's true but we
didn't have enough knowledge about how
much load the system is done in the
mobile game generally it's a lot tends
to increase at the moment a new event
opens the figures rise shows the example
was estimated to because past second in
a realistic event this is a trial
calculation the class per second will
increase to several hundreds in ten
minutes we have to check in advance if
the system can withstand like this load
as a point we notice we can not will
predict the action where I as a batch
processing at regular intervals our
system has to respond to the request
from the player from a player in
real-time
that is where he puts where the edge
repeats the character in the next one to
achieve this we can be chose the only
prediction API of the credible engine
we've checked if the claudemir engine
can satisfy our requirements by
performing the Lord testings in advance
of release in our case the testing was
performed in the setting of the request
increased linearly and reach a max of
1,000 requests per second we found a
doramin engine cannot escape quickly in
response to the request and average the
latency of the prediction is less than
one second however they were sure that
took a longer time than usual since this
might not be possible to request the
return request to the prayer so we
needed resolve this condition our DNA
team and credible engine team cooperated
to investigate bottlenecks and then we
found the timeout has happened
when the new instance is bombed up in
the process of the auto scaling due to
our heavy roll it is challenging to
handle large number of requests which
consists of many features at the same
time with only prediction but if we can
resolve this problem by building I've
seen such gent backend systems we don't
have to warm up the system beforehand
and the system will be more robust so
our team took a time to deal with this
program let's take a look at let's take
a look at how we tackle to remove errors
when the error returns with when the
error returns within a time the we can
simple we can simply throw it back again
to the service but in the case of time
out the system cannot send it back again
because a timeout error is not returned
therefore when the inference API server
does not receive the response within
five seconds the request is sent back to
the API again because something bad has
happened in the inference also if the
destination was oppressed is the same
endpoint it will further increase the
load on the server as a result we set on
as a backup endpoint to receive us that
fails to be operated in the main
endpoint that is the second request is
sent a sent to the backup endpoint which
is prepared independently from the main
endpoint this is a result of Lauro
testing with backup endpoint the figure
shows the error rates of several
settings no backup backup is Temenos and
back off with twenty minimum knows in
the case without backup endpoint on the
left about 1.3 percent of errors
remained in the middle setting of the
back Avista me mum knows all those small
error still
and the backup can deal with most of the
main endpoint errors we found the reason
of this small error is because number of
the backup instances was small a bit so
the time at has still happened at the
warm-up of the auto-scaling in the
backup environment the rightmost case is
a fine-tuned setting where as a number
of backup instance was set to 24
covering the errors of main endpoint
sufficiently in this case we could
handle all the requests without errors
so in this video and claudemir Engine
team got over the challenge of high and
spikey traffic and latency limit without
errors after deployment this system has
been stable in handling many errors so
far I've explained always when the
system all of our AI and the system
which disappear can be constructed
flexibly to cope with various problems
for gaming so now I'd like to hand over
to Jim for the KPI result and future
thanks Thank You Ricky and the athlete
he mentioned the we needed a scalable
and robust system to actually implement
this AI in the emitter rear cases so in
this final part we would like to share
what happened after the release so first
for the dick recommendation here is the
chart which shows the number of pinners
who used the correct mentation there
were constant usage after the release
but in at this time
dysfunctional was not well known but the
station has been changed after we
started an in-game event to promote
players to build new decks the deck
recommendation system has been
recognized more and even after the event
has been finished many players are still
using this function frequently so second
we are very glad that the recommended
recommended deck push the win rate of
the beginners by about five percent
compared to decks created without the
recommendation system since our focus
was to support [ __ ]
we are very satisfied with these results
also I'd like to mention that this
function has good adoption even even for
top tier players this was sort of
byproduct but we're observing that heavy
players usually update their deck
frequently and this recommendation
system litigates the cost of building
deck from scratch they use
recommendation as a first suggestion and
then customize the deck as they want so
let's look at the system matrix as well
after the release we have a stable
latency of 20 military fast enough for
our cases and but we are very surprised
by the result because the recommendation
algorithm is very complex and we haven't
expected such a role and I see the auto
scaling does a good job as well and we
haven't had any system trouble so far so
briefly we will explain about the
evaluation of deep learning AI bots
after the release we are observing that
our a boat has good enough we rate as a
practice partner for [ __ ] our area
bots can beat even talk to your players
and therefore the players can choose any
levels of AI as a sort of mentor
although this was released last weekend
that we don't have enough data to
evaluate the business impact dojo is
used by being very well and we hope this
can lead could kaypea in the future so
as to the latency the interests of
machine learning engines is about 200 to
300 music and very fast and stable even
for the end
system the response time is about a
second which is enough fuss for our case
backup endpoint is working well and we
haven't had any system trouble so far so
to the end of my talk I'll show items
which worked well in our cases so to
train the AI that played a game like a
human we need but battlelog that
completely reproduce battle status and
actions so if you have some random
effects in the game make sure that the
random C's are stored in the logs
secondary for the evaluation of our AI
we needed to run thousands of battles to
get performance statistics headless
simulator helped us a lot in this
context if you want to try to use
reinforcement learning techniques
you also need very fast simulator
because the number of battles there
algorithm goes through really mutters
answered we also want to stress that
scalable and robust system is required
for implementing AI in VR services we
think that CCP in particular machine
learning and Jian GE were a good choice
for us the last item is not technical
but critical generally speaking we don't
know how well a I will perform and how
big the business impact will be before
starting a project so in such a certain
situation the communication and
controlling the expectation is very
important although we are machine
learning engineers we try to understand
the game and business issue correctly
and I think that this was a key factor
of the success of these projects so this
is from me and I like to pass somebody
to submit again thanks
okay thank you
ginsa and ichi-san for this amazing
presentation I think it's inspired a lot
of people here today and it's very
impressive the work they have done to
make their game a bit more inclusive and
a bit more friendly to beginners and I
hope that what they have implemented
will be very successful and that today's
presentation can help you maybe have
some ideas and so just two before
closing this session I want just to show
you some use single use case that you
could start with using a machine
learning and I will talk quickly about
two that don't with much require ml
expertise and one that's very similar to
what they have done so starting by this
one the chat translation so one of the
big problem in game is like the language
barrier and so I strongly see that in
the region where I come from Japan where
players are just speaking Japanese and
you will never see a game that has like
multipe community of people from Japan
playing with Korean and Taiwanese people
because the language and so if you want
to break that barrier you can start by
using this kind of pre trained model
like translation API to to translate
chat messages in real time and to break
those kind of barrier it would be so
good to have more integrated community
within the game that could go beyond
frontiers so this is one use case that
you could really start very quickly and
if you have ever tried the translation
Google translation you see that it's
very accurate and even though it might
not be perfect in the language of a game
it will still be better than having
communities that cannot communicate
communicate each other the second one is
one that I seen like every gaming
companies are trying to fight is the
player toxicity sometime in your game
you might have some people that might
bully some other player and that can
break a bit to game and so you don't
want to lose important
players because of the player bad
players behavior you could start on
Google cloud platform on GCP using
natural language processing API that has
a functional itical sentiment analysis
so what sentiment analysis is doing is
you it would take attacks as an input
and will be able to tell you if it's a
positive input or a negative input that
has been known based on a lot of data
that you would be able to take you could
maybe detect very negative inside from
players and to want them maybe to depend
them if it's really like at that point
but you don't want maybe to go manually
to check every single chat or action of
players to decide if that person is
toxic you could get this kind of API to
bring you inside on potential problems
in your game and potential players that
are dealing maybe problems in your
gaming that can damage it in the end so
these are two use cases that can be
start very quickly using pre trained
models the last one which will require a
bit more expertise and I think that's
very similar to what DNA has done today
is simplifying games and I think today
what DNA has done is a perfect example
what is simplification of game using AI
and they made their Dec recommendation
to simplify a bit the construction of
the games when you have too many
characters possibly and also having like
a way to train against a boat is also a
way to train and help people ramp up so
you could also seen from other use cases
and one that I always hear from Studios
is the Q&A so the QA testing not QA QA
testing so QA testing is cost a lot of
money because you need to test every
time you do some changes you need to
test if this doesn't break for instance
balance of your game in the mobile
mobile space and even now in console
because you start to see that the latest
game like for tonight gets weekly
updates to bring you new items in the
game you want if you will be able to
automate this kind of testing you
be able to be sure that when you bring a
new item or a new card in your game it
doesn't break the balance of the game
and usually I can see from being in
Japan and playing the Japanese game on
mobile that brings like new item new
character every two weeks sometime a
character will break the balance I even
see on fortnight sometimes they bring a
new weapon and it's too strong and they
immediately take action but you would
like to act before doing that before
going in production with your update if
you be able to create a automation boat
like they did that would be one of the
Yusuke that could be interesting in and
I think like to do this kind of seeing
you you'll be able to use tensorflow
machine learning engine and do something
very similar to what DNA did and I hope
that what the presentation from DNA
inspired you and gave you some insight
of how you bring an approach a problem
that's as complex as maybe a human
simulated boat but I hope that will be
helpful for you and I think we have a
little time I think we have ten minutes
more so if you have any questions I
think we ichi-san Jensen please comment
in the on the stage and if you have any
question I think they have a mic in the
back and feel free to ask question if
you want to talk a bit more deeper about
something or a challenge that you have
been having we can discuss after the
session so thank you very much
[Applause]
and your question up so first thank you
for your talk
um when training your AI based on
different skill levels so to play
against beginners versus playing against
experts did you ask the cloud system the
ml system for multiple inferences or did
you train it differently did you train
it on games for people who lose
frequently as opposed to just experts so
your question is that we only train with
top tier players log 4 oh yeah that's
want to Train it so that it sometimes
loses to beginners so how did you
accomplish that goal - you mean that to
train their levels so we have invented
some schemes - for that adjustment and
the so if so we inference for every term
the score of the movie right so for
example there is a like ten moves we
sort the evaluated score and we tick the
the most highest score of two for the
Amidah to be strong right but we are
optimizing that score by selecting some
I mean the second and third best move in
a certain probability and that's the
hyper parameter and we're tuning
manually that parameters so that's why
we are we could balance the levels
according to the player's building the
game but did you use a reinforcement
learning or structure may be different
results with different models so in this
case we are not using but we are trying
and actually the problem here is that
the inference from running is very
unstable - especially in this kind of
strategic game so we are trying but the
we read is not so
I like supervised learning a what
although thanks for talk again so you
had nine months of data and billions of
logs to start if you were to put this
system into a brand-new game nine months
is a very long time and a lot of players
mayority come and churn so what would be
you know an ideal what would be sort of
the theoretical minimum could you put
this in at the start and learn as you go
would you need to wait some amount of
time yeah actually like a two week or
one month data is enough for our case so
dymas is kind of buffer so I think it's
too much to use nine months data but you
you are measuring the course start
problem so in that case maybe I need we
need like one month data or a few weeks
data before I mean the training and
here's a question over there
yes by the way thank you for the very
good questions it's very good point
the nature of the games these days is
that the rules of the games change
frequently especially with game updates
and that changes the nature of how the
path should be playing how do you plan
to deal with that point and actually
we're releasing like a few characters
every week and the game has changed
time by time so but the hour I mean a
deeper any frameworks works even for
that cases because just after using like
one week for a few days
data the a I'd become to adapt to how to
say the the latest environments so there
is kind of one week delay but in this
case I think we are acceptable so yeah
that's that's answer for the questions
what are what are the problems are you
trying to tackle so your question is
that what's the problem
currently we have or is there any other
type of problem that you're considering
tackling other than what you present it
today there's any other problem that you
want to solved using so I mentioned but
very impossible Ani but actually we want
to keep the game balance very stable and
before releasing the characters right so
we wanted to implement very enforcement
learning engine to learn the brand new
characters before ladies and then check
if the balance is not too much I mean
I'm the string so strong or weak or
something like that so that might be the
next challenge
hi in regards to your inputs what data
are you discarding or you using
everything you've captured since the
beginning or everything from the last
patch for the last two patches or
updates rather 5 kilo features exerted
for them from the board like what kind
of skills is activated or in the last
turn what was what happened or something
that yeah are you at all worried that
the legacy data can excuse yes as you
introduce more characters more options
this that are you worried that you know
the very old data that didn't know about
all this new stuff kind of skews the
recommendations or what the
functionality over time how do you
handle the new type of data that you
didn't have before yeah that's the
biggest problem we have now
country we are so every time
we release a new skills we are tuning
the feature extractor and they make it
to create a new features but that the
operational cost is very high so we want
to somehow optimize that process so and
your other question okay I think like if
you if you want to talk a bit more in
detail like oh we stay on the right of
the on the left of the stage so free
free to come by and ask any question
other than that I want to thank you
again for today it was really great and
thank everyone for joining us today
[Applause]